[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events if you'd like to
see us on the road head on over to
theminimalists.com to find a city near
you or you can watch recordings of all
of our live events over at patreon.com
the minimalists enjoy
hey it's wes hey wes what's on your mind
so i've heard it put by rich role we are
either growing or regressing as a
minimalist when you are working to meet
your personal goals spiritual physical
financial how do you continue to have
peace and be content in the present
moment while working on your future
goals
okay i heard a lot of words here
i'm going to talk about them
individually
tk maybe you you can help we can go do a
back and forth between the three of us
here so
the first word i heard rich roll is a
really good friend of ours he's been on
our podcast the second most times next
to tk coleman
and um
are you either growing you're regressing
i don't like the framing of that at all
maybe in context it makes a whole lot
more sense but there are two types of
growth right we talk about this in the
book as well so there is growth for the
sake of growth
never-ending gdp we need to grow expand
more more more at any cost right
okay
that sounds like cancer to me
that's what cancer does it grows no
matter what
so we think of growth as it being good
growth isn't inherently good or bad the
question is is it growth for the sake of
growth if so why or
is it intentional growth is there a
reason that i
want to grow
and i also heard something about goals
and how to and so we could talk about
some of these other things here as well
yeah man uh so i i think about i think
about this verse in the bible that says
uh it's better to give than to receive
and i remember thinking the first time i
heard that like that's totally not true
it's so better to receive than to give
we all know that
you know
but
i i think what it means is that
to receive is to be in a a consciousness
of lack to receive is to say i need i
need and you're identified with a state
of need it's a it's impossible to give
without thinking of yourself as someone
who has something to offer and so i
think the meaning there is it is always
better to carry yourself with a
consciousness of abundance seeing
yourself as having something to offer
anyone and everyone that you meet no
matter what the circumstances and
conditions of your life are
than to see yourself as someone who is
constantly at the mercy of what other
people do for you
what does that have to do with growth i
think there are two models for growth
one is you can grow from a state of lack
i'm trying to grow because i'm not worth
anything i'm trying to grow because i'm
not good enough i'm trying to go grow
because until i get that level of income
or until i acquire those things or until
i achieve that level of status i won't
be a player in the game i won't be worth
anything or you can grow from a state of
abundance and say i am already all that
i need to be and i am seeking to grow
not in order to become that which i am
not but in order to manifest what i
already am so my growth is not in
intaking my growth is an outpouring and
i think that kind of growth is healthy
so are you growing from a state of
trying to achieve worthiness or are you
growing from a state of self-acceptance
where you are seeking to generally
genera general general
generous
generous
generously
channel edit that out share who you are
with other people
[Laughter]
oh man
uh you know it's interesting i'll
highlight what milburn has said about
you know minimalism it's not about the
doing minimalism it's about the not
doing
so you know i don't have advice on
how do you do minimalism but also work
towards your goals and achievements and
that sounds really stressful to me
actually i'm not going to lie
but um but that's not a judgment it just
it just it just is um
but yeah the uh the whole point is is to
stop the doing if i was to tell someone
if i was to tell you tk
be in the moment
be in the moment right now hurry
no you're not being in the moment i'm
everywhere but the moment oh the
moment's already gone right exactly
that's exactly right you are everywhere
but the moment when you're trying to be
in the moment and and i think you know
when it comes to
yeah achievements and success
and you know success is something i
chase so much
in my mid-20s and you know maybe i would
get a little bit of it but as soon as
you get some of it you want more
especially if you are chasing success
so for me you know i had to redefine
really what success was in a way i don't
really call it success it's really just
it's living a meaningful life it's it's
being a genuine person it's being myself
i mean
when you look in the mirror what do you
think so so do you have goals and
achievements for yourself
oh no
yeah no no no no i haven't had goals in
10 years
what do you mean but you don't want to
sell like a certain amount of books and
you know i do a certain amount of tours
no but our our whole that's a great
question though yeah yeah no it's a very
good question because you would think
there would be some type of metric or
like how many followers or how many
downloads these things are great and
like i don't look at them too much
because i'm i'm a numbers guy and i
actually obviously from my talk you
could tell i'm a numbers guy
um
and i love the numbers so if i was to
look at those on a regular basis i would
start to fixate on them so i avoid that
because i know that's one of my
weaknesses but our whole philosophy
really is low expectations high
standards
low expectations high standards
so what that means like with this book
for example
is like we really wanted to write a book
uh a relationship book not just about
people but about these important
relationships in our lives and we really
wanted to show
how having a healthy relationship with
these uh with these seven things in our
lives how that can really help us live a
meaningful life people ask us all the
time hey man you know i get it you had
success you had the money you had the
cars whatever what you know i get it it
doesn't make it doesn't uh make you
happy but i just want to try it out for
myself and i don't know why i still want
to try it out for myself but i just want
to try it out for myself it reminds me
of my favorite philosopher jim carrey
what does he say i wish everyone could
be rich and famous so they could see
that that's not the answer
and when someone would ask me that how
do i get rid of that
desire
i don't i didn't really know how to
answer that there's not a lightning
round or a pithy answer that i could say
like well here's how you stop those
desires but through this book
like that is where i saw an opportunity
i'm like oh
like when we can focus on these things
which take no money by the way all these
things we can focus on with time and
attention
that is when those desires will start to
fade away a little bit
so that you can see like why we wrote
this book so that was our that was our
our goal if you want to call it a goal
i'm happy to call it a goal um
we we did that with our best ability in
the best way we could with the best
words we could we we formatted it we
made it as beautiful as we could our
standard was super high with this book
but our expectation
was so low if it was just one person who
read it and was like
i really enjoyed that book
i mean that would have been worth it
heck if if i would have read it like oh
this is a good book that would have been
worth it
but to sit here and be like oh we got to
be on you know
we
i don't even want to mention this
because it sounds like kind of
braggadocious but we did make the new
york times bestseller list okay
but you know what that means stop it's
ridiculous that people buy they spend
thousands hundreds of thousands of
dollars to be on their list they game
the system we didn't but like it doesn't
matter it's not important i was going to
talk about josh's reaction and you're
seeing it right now
it's here's here's the problem no i to
my the honest answer to your question
and i'm not prescribing this to you i'm
not saying don't have goals i'm not
saying that they're useless for you i'm
saying they're a problem for me
and and here's why they're a problem i
was the goal guy in the corporate world
and i had spreadsheets of goals here the
24 goals and sub goals to the goals and
they stress me out they made me
miserable because i could figure out how
to achieve those goals but the how-to is
the thing that keeps me stressed out why
because i was so focused on becoming i
wasn't i had no idea what it meant to be
i was becoming the person i thought i
wanted to become
but throughout that process there was
very little
being me and as soon as you become that
thing you get the promotion that you
want or the car that you want or the
so-called success that you want we did
this exercise last night in atlanta i
said to the crowd you know describe a
wealthy person anytime i or a successful
person rather anytime i do this it's
always the same answers if i show you a
magazine ad with a successful person
what's it look like it's a guy usually
in a suit with a luxury car and a yacht
and a roll it's always a watch of some
sort right
they always look the same and there's
nothing inherently wrong with those
things
we all need some stuff and by the way
it's not that lexus is a bad thing i'm
sure they make wonderful cars i used to
own two of them because i felt
inadequate
and so we do a lot of things
why
because we feel inadequate and we want
other people's approval or praise or
adulation or validation in order to say
you know what i am adequate
but that's a chase all these things
we're talking about we can use fancy
nice words goals like oh that's a good
thing let's call it what it is it's a
chase it's striving
it's an attachment to an outcome and
those are the things that make me
miserable
yeah
i want to oh less
less about achievements and goals and
more about living a meaningful life for
sure living like right now living like
i'm so grateful to be here and whether
there was you know a thousand people or
three people here i'm we've done tour
stops literally where two people showed
up
knoxville 10 years ago i missed those
days two people showed up you still do
it hell yeah we did
and it was one of the best tour stops
we've ever had why
high standard
low expectation that's right hey i just
want to tell you man like you are a
beautiful human being man and like no
matter what your goals are that's cool
man but you don't need those goals to be
a beautiful human being because i'll
tell you that when i was in the
corporate world world chasing the
success
i and what really got me started on the
road of minimalism is i couldn't look in
the mirror anymore
having all that success having the cars
in the house and the vacations and the
raises and the management and the
employees and my employees employees
like that didn't help me see
any better of a person in the mirror
and so there's nothing wrong with these
accolades there's nothing wrong with
these
you know if it doesn't bother me we made
it on the new york times bestseller list
i think it's pretty freaking cool but
that's not why we did it
but when that becomes the why
when all those things become the why
it's really hard to look in the mirror
thank you guys and thanks for being in
nashville thank you brother thank you
ma'am
i just want to say something to them
about this goals and ambition thing is i
think the important question to always
be asking yourself is what what game am
i playing am i playing a game that
expresses my aliveness a game that i've
created for myself or am i playing a
game that someone else created for me
and i'm hustling really hard to try to
win prizes that i don't really care
about
there's a book by james p cars called
finite and infinite games and there's a
line in there that's so beautiful where
he says the first rule of play is that
he who must play cannot play if you are
compelled to play
from some externally directed force then
it's not play it's not a game and it
feels
it feels stressful it feels compulsive
it feels unhealthy and you resent it and
so many people
their goals are unhealthy because
they're playing games that other people
want them to play which means they're
not experiencing these games as play but
as human beings it's our nature to play
the moment our needs are met the first
thing we do is we find a game to play we
create goals that are unimportant but
that are still worth doing because the
essence of play is not to do something
because it's important in some external
sense but because it expresses our joy
and so whatever you do in life like it's
okay to say here's something that i
haven't done and i want to do it here's
a place that i haven't gone and i want
to go but go and do and create and be
and seek after things for the purpose of
playfully expressing who you are not for
the purpose of pleasing somebody that
when it really comes down to it you
don't you don't even care about and they
don't even you know represent your own
priorities and principles
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free